so the trailer for Avengers and game has
just dropped and already the internet is
abuzz with theories and ideas about what
the film could contain throughout this
video I'll be giving my fan theory on a
few things that I think will happen in
the film there will of course be heavy
spoilers so if you don't want anything
rune for you then I highly suggest that
you turn off now but everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so the first question you
may have when watching the trailer is
what is up with Hawkeye well fans of the
comic already know that Clint Barton aka
Hawkeye adopts the alias ronan after he
rejoins the avengers following the print
version of Civil War multiple characters
have used the moniker and it tends to be
adopted by those who descent from
society perhaps because of the collapse
of it or because of the death of
Hawkeye's family in the trailer we
witnessed an ass strolling through a
field akin to the visions in gladiator
it appears that he is very heavily
battle damaged still which shows that
perhaps all of the power from the stones
is gone as he could have just used them
to heal himself there have been rumors
of another villain in the film and this
weakened state that he is in could show
that the heroes finally have a chance of
stopping him ant-man is back somehow
from the quantum realm and this is
perhaps because he has mastered it
leaked photos from the Avengers forset
show that the heroes returned to the
battle of New York and perhaps his
control of this has enabled him to
return to certain time periods in
Avengers history hopefully after the
final fight this ability also allows him
to grant Steve to return to the 40s and
live out the life that he would have had
with Peggy Cora had he not been robbed
of that final dance Steve is still
clearly hung up on it so this would be a
deserving finale for the character and
hope it's the way that he goes out so
what are your thoughts on the trailer
and where do you think the events will
lead to comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of into the spider-verse which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for take the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace